général de gaulle quand il est arrivé au
pouvoir a dit à l'armée française
votre mission est de garder l'algérie
est de garder et de la garde et
française
vous devez y déployer tout tout votre
ardeur et tout votre volonté ce champ
ces mots propres
je n'ai pas fait un choix personnel pour
l'algérie française
le pouvoir français mayer ma hiérarchie
militaire m'a donné l'ordre de garder
l'algérie à la france dans une guerre où
l'enjeu était la population il fallait
donc dire à cette population vous
resterez ce trait français et vous
n'avez aucune crainte à avoir jamais la
france ne vous abandonnera
bolzano
l'élevage des volailles
[Musique]
à
l'école
vaches des poules al noura
j'adhère
au
quatrième as
[Musique]
contre la bolivie 1 1
la guerre durait depuis cinq ans et le
président de gaulle avait conscience que
l'armée détenait la clé de toute
solution politique comme militaire en
cet été 2009 159 il se rendit en algérie
pour se montrer aux populations mais
aussi pour consulter ses généraux
c'était à eux qu'il devait être à
nouveau au pouvoir mais leur
indiscipline leurs terres durant ces
douze derniers mois les éléments les
plus rebelles avaient été écartés mais
il n'était pas possible d'en faire plus
alors que la guerre continuait
les succès remportés récemment avait
relevé le moral de l'armée mais il était
dû surtout aux unités musulmane les
harkis ce qui amenait d'autres
complications les officiers qui les
commandait avait acquis un tel respect
pour leurs hommes qu'il s'était juré de
ne jamais les abandonner un serment que
certains se souvenaient de n'avoir pu
tenir envers nos unités vietnamienne en
indochine et se souvenir ne faisait que
les renforcer dans leur volonté de tenir
parole cette fois ci un facteur dont de
gaulle ne tient jamais compte
quant au problème des pieds noirs ces
colons européens il ne l'intéressait pas
davantage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans 59 je tiens les propos à votre
disposition il m'a tout à fait dit que
la plainte d'intégration il la ferait il
n'a pas du tout dit ce qu'il allait
faire il c'est là qu'il m'a dit
l'algérie ne va pas est morte parce
qu'il disait qu'elle vous il fallait
évoluer mais il n'a jamais parlé
d'indépendance et au contraire quand il
a parlé du fln en disant ils veulent ma
pause et de dire et de faire telle chose
mais ça je ne le ferai jamais vous
pouvez lire les textes de l'époque pour
la grande masse des français d'algérie
il est évident que la politique du jard
le gaulois t2 senti ressenti comme une
politique d'abandon par rapport aux
engagements que le général de gaulle
avait pris lors de ses première venue en
algérie notamment juin 58 lorsqu'il a
prononcé le fameux discours de
mostaganem où il a dit vive l'algérie
française et bien entendu les français
d'algérie ils ont été confrontés à des
drames de conscience qui se sont
exprimées au cours des différentes
périodes de révolte de leur part que ce
sont les barricades le putsch et
notamment l' os cette politique de
trahison par rapport aux engagements qui
avaient été pris a été ressenti très
très profondément par les français
d'algérie qui ont vu que la france
métropolitaine ne ne confirmait pas les
engagements qui avaient été pris en 1958
et notamment lors du référendum de
septembre 58
de gaulle durant ses séjours algérien
passé de plus en plus de temps parmi les
musulmans négligeant les européens dans
l'opinion à ses yeux n'importait plus
guère vieilles rancunes des et en
remontant à la guerre mondiale et à leur
manque de soutien il cherchait celui des
musulmans qui d'abord méfiantes la
docteure
facebook
exchange grosse way des deux pieds noirs
trop de gameplay en 2d
où
il faut comprendre la réaction des
français d'algérie par rapport à ce
principe intangible de pérennité
française en algérie qui s'inscrivait
dans le cadre de la constitution
française et à partir du moment où une
politique du merlan français déroger à
ce droit est à ce droit imprescriptible
il est évident que ça ne pouvait
entraîner qu'une qu'un sentiment de
révolte de la part des français
d'algérie
cette révolte ne tarda pas il est
rancune accumulée contre de gaulle
éclaté au grand jour au début de 1960
les militants pieds noirs qui
fréquentaient ces bars de la ville basse
d'alger appelé à une grève générale le
24 janvier avec les habituels
démonstration au monument aux morts
mais sans attendre ce jour les
barricades cher à la tradition
révolutionnaire françaises commençaient
à s'élever dans les principales artères
conduisant au centre de la ville le but
était d'empêcher l'intervention de
l'armée
on installe un des premiers postes de
secours bien que les dirigeants
pieds-noirs et reçu l'assurance de
certains officiers que l'armée ne
tirerait pas
la révolte était loin d'être aussi
spontané que ces chefs que voulait le
faire croire à preuve l'implantation
méthodique des barricades et l'abondance
de vivre permettant de tenir en cas de
siège par l'armée une armée dont les
parents en particulier était plus que
conciliant
de ce côté
plus inquiétante est l apparition dans
les rues d'alger de forces
paramilitaires en chemise brune bien
disciplinés et qui se mêlait à la
jeunesse pieds noirs en tenue de
territoriaux tous portaient des armes
volées pour la plupart dans les dépôts
de l'armée les révoltes et miser sur la
passivité de l'armée certains espéraient
même qu'elle se joindrait à eux
obligeant par la de gaulle à renoncer à
ses promesses aux musulmans et à opter
pour une algérie française s'était
montré une grande naïveté et ignorait
totalement le caractère du président
les actualités de l'époque décrivent la
révolte comme un vaste pique nique avec
la complicité visible de l'armée
mais ce n'était pas toujours ainsi comme
le prouvent les funérailles des quatorze
gendarmes tués durant ces manifestations
du 24 janvier au monument aux morts
les malheureux envoyé pour contrôler la
foule avait été abattu alors qu'il se
croyait soutenus par des parents mais
ceux-ci arrivèrent trop tard leur
officier étant de mèche avec les
manifestants
des français avec tuer d'autres français
une situation nouvelle dans les drames
algérien dorénavant tout compromis avec
les rebelles devenait impossible
[Musique]
l'armée replica à retardement en
décrétant l'état de siège dans une ville
où les manifestations ont succédé aux
manifestations les rumeurs de putsch
circulaient et de fête nombreux étaient
les officiers supérieurs qui
souhaitaient se débarrasser de de gaulle
à l'occasion de cette révolte
par une température exceptionnelle pour
la saison la garde aux barricades
devenait une partie de plaisir cependant
de france ne parvenait aucun signe de
soutien et de gaulle bien qu'embarrassé
ne prenait pas la situation au tragique
jamais le général de gaulle n'a dû faire
face à un problème plus difficile son
pouvoir il le doit en grande partie au
soutien des pieds noirs ces mêmes pieds
noirs qui maintenant parle de guerre
civile le court voyage en algérie du
premier ministre monsieur debré semble
n'avoir donné aucun résultat
on ne sait toujours pas si le président
de la république compte se rendre à son
tour en algérie certains lui reprochent
d'avoir attendu trop longtemps face à la
droite algérienne n'oublions pas que ce
sont les européens d'algérie qui les
premiers cris hier de gaulle au pouvoir
des forces paramilitaires observer
scrupuleusement tous les rites d'une
armée espérant peut être acquérir ainsi
une certaine légitimité
mais un des traits de caractère des
pieds-noirs et l'impatience celle ci
allait leur être fatal le temps ne
travaillait pas pour eux malgré leurs
efforts pour faire croire au ralliement
les musulmans de fait quelques-uns les
rejoignirent mais ce n'était plus les
masses de mai 58
[Musique]
les barricades avaient été érigées pour
des combats et ceux qui les gardait
espérait bien combattre comme rien ne se
passait ils commencèrent à se quereller
sur ce qu'il apportait le faire l'ennui
c'est que personne n'y avait songé il
avait supposé que l'initiative viendrait
de l'armée et de gouvernement l'armée
prendrait la tête de la révolte comment
58 le gouvernement accéderait à leurs
exigences par exemple en suspendant
l'autodétermination comme rien ne se
passe et que l'armée se désolidariser 2
et que le gouvernement les ignorer
grande fut leur humiliation
significatif aussi le fait que les seuls
musulmans allaient rejoindre étaient les
anciens combattants des deux guerres les
jeunes s'abstenait visiblement
en france chaque jour qui passe est
renforcé l'opinion contre les pieds
noirs sans support de l'armée ceux ci
étaient de plus en plus heures
la parente fraternité entre les rebelles
et les anciens combattants musulmans
l'impressionné pas de gaulle tous mes
conseillers d'agir lui savaient qu'ils
n'avaient qu'à se montrer patient
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le prétexte de la rébellion avait été le
déplacement par de gaulle duffy delmas
où mathieu était un des rares officiers
avoir joué un rôle important dans le
putsch au 2 mai 58 et à avoir échappé
aux purges depuis la bataille d'alger
deux ans auparavant il était l'idole des
pieds noirs
au cours d'une interview extorqués par
un journaliste allemand lui même ancien
para massue avait critiqué de gaulle de
gaulle l'avait donc muté occasion pour
les pieds noirs de montrer leur
opposition à un président qui parlait
d'autodétermination au peuple algérien
[Musique]
au moment choisi par lui le 29 janvier
sixième jour de la révolte vêtu de son
uniforme de gaulle s'adressa à la nation
j'ai pris au nom de la france la
décision que voici
les algériens
disposera librement de leur destin
quand d'une manière ou d'une autre
conclusion d'un cessez le feu ou
écrasement de phase iib rebelles
nous aurons misa interne qu'au bar
et corps après une période prolongée
d'apaisement les populations
ont pu prendre conscience de l'enjeu
et accomplir grâce à nous
certains progrès politiques économiques
sociaux colère et cetera club
les algeria dire ans qui le veulent
peuvent
cela ne leur sera pas dictée
en dépit de leur attitude patriotique
les pieds noirs ni carrière sans larmes
ni de gaulle le savez mieux que
quiconque
[Musique]
il décida d'en appeler directement au
loyalisme des officiers mais surtout des
soldats du comptage un pari mais les
chances étaient bas
mais
aucun soldat à aucun moment et même
passivement
le droit
s'associer à la rébellion
un fan corps
l'indre public déjà être rétabli
oui il peut y avoir des moyens de
diverses face
pour que force reste à la loi
mais vous devez y parvenir c'est lorsque
j'ai donné et c'est l'ordre que je donne
ce discours marqué pour les rebelles le
commencement de la fin il n'aurait pu
mieux tomber ne contenant aucune
nouvelle proposition il ne revenait sur
aucune promesse au milieu de la
confusion générale lui seul paraissait
déterminer c'était exactement ce
qu'attendait la france soudain
apparurent des renforts les
parachutistes cessèrent tout
fraternisation les milices des
barricades se débandent est les jusqu'au
boutistes se défouler dans des heurts
violents avec la police et l'armée dont
les officiers après avoir été tenté par
la rébellion ordonnée maintenant de la
balayer
[Applaudissements]
les pieds noirs conscient d'avoir manqué
leur coup et de n'être plus qu'un
facteur négligeable dans l'équation qui
résout pas le problème algérien
sombrèrent dans le désespoir
[Applaudissements]
tandis que dans les plus sales bagarre
que la police d'alger et jamais dû
affronter les français échanger entre
eux coups de poing et coups de pied
barres de fer contre matraque les
musulmans regardait narquois le fln
n'était plus le seul rebelle
[Applaudissements]
ce fln qui brusquement se manifester par
une série d'attentats aveugles en plein
centre d'alger réel moyen de rappeler
qu'ils étaient les vrais rebelles
comble de malheur le temps celui de la
partie le jour où de gaulle par là il
s'est mis à pleuvoir et son discours fut
ponctuée de coups de tonnerre coup dur
pour le moral
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la révolte traînaient encore 48 heures
puis les barricades furent démantelées
paris avait venger l'humiliation
infligée au président du mollet quatre
ans plus tôt la populace d'alger avait
finalement été vaincu
une semaine exactement après la
fusillade des quatorze gendarmes les
dernières milices d'insurgés capitulaire
défilant en armes et drapeaux en tête
pierre lagaillarde de leur chef dit
adieu à son père avant d'être embarqué
pour une prison en france les autres
dirigeants devaient être jugés dans le
courant de l'année les peines furent
légère
leur échec convainquit des pieds noirs
qu'ils n'étaient rien sans l'armée elle
seule pourrait conserver l'algérie
française de gaulle le savez bien et il
mute à un grand nombre d'officiers dont
trois généraux au cours d'une nouvelle
purge
les milices furent envoyés dans le
désert pour former une unité spéciale de
la légion étrangère qui s'illustra dans
des combats contre les maquis fln puis
fut dissoute discrètement
[Musique]
le bulldozer de l'armée razr les
barricades et la vie à alger retourna
rapidement à la normale mais ce n'était
qu'une apparence trompeuse une étape
avait été franchie
quelques la plupart des colons ne le
réalisais repas obsédé qu'ils étaient
par leurs récriminations
spd
comme pour souligner la victoire de de
gaulle la france fait exploser sa
première bombe atomique peu de jours
après la chute des barricades les ondes
devait atteindre alger
est bien plus les années passaient plus
de gaulle avait la conviction que
l'avenir de la france n'était pas dans
le maintien de la colonisation en
algérie ou ailleurs il était convaincu
que la france devait se moderniser
devait s'industrialiser qu'elle devait
avoir le regard tourné vers l'avenir et
pas vers le maintien de conquête du
passé qui lui coûtait cher en hommes et
en argent est de plus en plus on a senti
quand on le voyait en privé mais
également quand on entend des ses
discours qu'il souhaitait approché de la
fin du problème algérien
de pétrole du sahara était d'un bel
exemple des problèmes que devait
résoudre le général sa découverte
coïncidait avec le début de la rébellion
et la france en touche et les premiers
dividendes alors que de gaulle revenait
au pouvoir les experts étaient persuadés
qu'il tenait là un trésor comparable à
celui des chèques du golfe persique
c'était exagéré mais à l'époque cette
conviction donné ok noir un argument de
plus pour ne pas lâcher l'algérie
l'armée soupçonnait un moment le lobby
anti coloniale à l'onu d'être financée
par les compagnies pétrolières
américaines jalouse la découverte
française les élèves officiers reçu même
un cours sur l'impérialisme américain
de gaulle était bien conscient de
l'importance du pétrole saharien pour la
grandeur de la france cette grande aire
dont l'obsession lui fit faire tant de
cas de la visite de khrouchtchev en mars
réception officielle à l'opéra de paris
peut-on imaginer deux hommes plus
différents que khrouchtchev et de gaulle
pourtant et de présidente en commun une
même inflexibilité qui les porte à
s'estimer mutuellement d'ailleurs dans
l'ensemble l'accueil du peuple français
est amicable un banquet offert en
l'honneur de monsieur k
la nourriture de celui ci est passé au
compteur geiger pas de radioactivité car
le camarade khrouchtchev
[Musique]
de toutes les visites que de gaulle fit
à cette époque la plus émouvante fut
celle de londres où il s'était juré de
ne revenir qu'en chef d'état
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
le président de gaulle ne peut cacher sa
profonde émotion il renoue avec ce long
trou pendant quatre années d'exil il dû
lutter pour être reconnus sans votre
soutien une fois l'entente dans son
destin
[Applaudissements]
c'est en chef d'état que le président de
gaulle arrive un peu pile gamme palace
il re si les mêmes ovation au canada et
aux etats unis son rôle pendant la
guerre en faisait un des quatre grands
la france revenait au premier rang des
nations
mais ses soucis à propos de l'armée
d'algérie ne le quittaient pas où qu'ils
aillent général challe avait au cours de
l'année remporté victoire après victoire
mais de gaulle ne lui pardonnait pas
l'attitude équivoque darné au début de
la semaine des barricades tout comme il
s'était déjà débarrassée des colonels et
des généraux dissidents il était décidé
à remplacer charles challes sans doute
est née réclamer un sursis pour conclure
sa campagne d'été par une victoire
définitive sur le fln cette victoire
définitive n'intéressait plus de gaulle
il voulait une solution politique en
algérie est une arme et déloyal y était
un obstacle challes fut rappelée en
avril 1960 ce limogeage ne fut pas la
manoeuvre la plus brillante du président
compte tenu surtout de la popularité du
commandant en chef dans l'armée comme
pour salants ce mépris aurait de graves
conséquences
mais de gaulle avait hâte de mettre fin
à la guerre
ah
je n'ai jamais cru que je pourrais d'un
instant à l'autre
trancher ce problème
posé depuis 130 ans mais je crois
que jamais on a été plus près d'aboutir
à une solution réelle
le 16 septembre
a été ouverte la route droite est clair
qui doit mener l'algérie vers la paix
le gouvernement a adopté le parlement a
approuvé cette décision de la france
il est vrai que ceux qui s'acharnent à
poursuivre une lutte fratricide
peuvent provoquer encore des accrochages
et des attentats mais c'est un fait
qu'il tombe chaque jour
quatre fois moins d'hommes auparavant
surtout
il et il n'est contesté
désormais nulle part
que l'autodétermination des algériens
quant à leur destin
soit la seule issue possible
de ce drame complexe et douloureux
je me tourne
vers les dirigeants de l'insurrection
je leur déclare que nous les attendons
ici
pour trouver avec eux
une fin honorable au combat qui se
traîne encore les yeux de mettre fin au
conflit et de régler définitivement le
problème
le gouvernement envisage de la
république algérienne et qui est envoyé
une délégation présidée par ferhat abbas
auront compris le général de gaulle
de gaulle recevait enfin une réponse
positive du effet la première étape vers
une solution politique
quand alger colis ses projets de
négociations la foule une fois plus que
se répandit dans les rues son désespoir
s'exprimer par la violence
[Applaudissements]
comme prévu les premiers pourparlers
avec le fln et n'aboutit à rien après
c'est si cruel année la paix ne serait
pas conclue facilement
cet échec fut un coup dur pour de gaulle
qui avait beaucoup attendu de ces
rencontres est une consolation pour les
pieds noirs
[Applaudissements]
de
même race 2000
et trop la
signe marseillaise olemps dizaine de
pieds noirs réfutent generali mais dans
90% des chiffres dieu
de gaulle avait ce que l'on appelle un
charisme à rayonnement assez mystérieux
et qui a fuit est une des grande partie
de sa grandeur qui s'est manifesté aussi
bien dans ses célèbres conférence de
presse que
lorsqu'il était un tout jeune général
qui qui qui relevait l'épée brisé de la
france en 40 41 et que je les ai vus
déjà à cette époque dans les coins les
plus reculés de la syrie ou du liban ou
de l'afrique noire les populations à
courait vers un homme exceptionnel et en
algérie si c'était pareil auprès de la
population je les ai reçus une fois dans
un coin que nous venions à peine de
pacifier je me suis beaucoup rapprochés
reprocher je m'emporte d'employer le mot
pacifié qui ne veut rien dire dans un
coin quand avait tranquilliser là et on
a vu toute la montagne sa chemise se
couvrir de chenilles de bourricot de
d'hommes de femmes de vieillards tout le
monde voulait avoir bu de gaulle ils
auront tout le monde répond on aurait pu
assassiner à la façon la plus banale du
monde est la plus simple mais on pouvait
le toucher on voulait le voir le meurtre
de de gaulle n'était pas une simple
menace comme le rappelle jean morin
délégué général en algérie
bombe a éclaté à tizi ouzou quelques
minutes avant l'arrivée du général de
gaulle à l'endroit même où il devait se
trouver ce qu'on sait c'est que toute la
journée du samedi 10 décembre
il a été indiqué de paris par assaf
nombre d'ambassades notamment par
l'ambassade d'israël quelles attentes at
je te diriger quand le général de gaulle
à l'entrée d'orléansville
il n'y eut pas moins de quatre
tentatives d'attentât durant cette seule
visite de gaulle était venu chercher des
voies pour ce référendum sur
l'autodétermination qui aurait lieu en
janvier 61
ce fut une visite désastreuse la
dernière qu'il ferait jamais
[Musique]
le référendum était pour les pieds noirs
comme la cape rouge pour le taureau il
était décidé à montrer à de gaulle leur
dégoût profond de la politique
algérienne qu'il voyait comme une volte
face après ses déclarations du début
pour une algérie française mais leurs
manifestations furent vaines de gaulle
évite à alger pour lui l'opinion des
pieds noirs ne comptait plus seul
importe l armée et la majorité musulmane
[Applaudissements]
les ultras parmi les colons espéré que
les forces de l'ordre à alger débordé
devrait faire appel à l'armée en
particulier aux parades dont certains
officiers une nouvelle fois penché de
leur côté mais les gendarmes et les crs
s'étaient organisés depuis les
barricades et avait touché quelques
blindés et ses actualités ne sont pas
sans rappeler les événements de budapest
quatre ans auparavant quand les chars
russes écraser la révolte des hongrois
[Musique]
la rage des pieds-noirs durera trois
jours les pertes furent l'aude dans la
police comme parmi les civils
alors que les boutiquiers évaluer les
dégâts soudain de la casbah et faubourg
apparurent des centaines de drapeaux du
fln les musulmans entrée en scène
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les chefs du fln était aussi décidé que
les pieds noirs à empêcher que cette
visite de de gaulle en algérie soit un
succès il ne voulait surtout pas qu'ils
en retirent un bénéfice politique qui
pourrait renforcer sa position dans les
négociations doute cette démonstration
de solidarité des musulmans avec le fln
il avait aussi un regard tourné vers le
nu on débattait pour savoir s'il fallait
soumettre ce problème algérien à
l'assemblée générale malgré l'opposition
de la france même dans son propre camp
de gaulle subissaient des critiques
il y a deux ans et demi ce n'est tout de
même pas si loin en mai 1958 nous avons
vu d'énormes manifestations à alger dans
toutes les villes de l'algérie et même
dans les villages mais c'étaient des
manifestations pacifiques les
manifestations deux fois de confiance et
de fraternité où les musulmans et les
européens ensemble a clamé la france
voilà qu'aujourd'hui il ya encore des
manifestations mais elles sont d'un
genre tout à fait différent les deux
communautés s'affrontent s'opposent et
bien entendu les agents provocateurs du
terrorisme peuvent trouver là l'occasion
ce qu'ils ont fait est las de déclencher
des airs et de faire couler le sang pour
tous ceux qui comme moi aime
profondément l'algérie c'est là un drame
absolument déchirant mais je pense qu'il
faut en tirer les conclusions et se
rendre compte que si nous en sommes
arrivés là c'est parce que après les
promesses qui a été qui ont été faites
en
1958 après l'annonce d'une politique qui
avait réussi à faire l'unité de toutes
les masses de la population algérienne
le fait que cette politique qui ait été
abandonnée que ces promesses n'ont pas
été tenues nous a conduit au résultat
que nous voyons
les bagarres entre européens s'arrêter
on fait bloc contre les musulmans le
choc fut sanglant il eu 120 morts dont
seulement 8 européen
[Applaudissements]
pour la première fois depuis trois ans
la casbah fut décrétée zone interdite
sauf pour la troupe et la police qui
montre est de moins en moins
d'enthousiasmé pour y pénétrer
la solution conforme au bon sens à
l'aise christique au génie de la france
est proposée à la décision du pays
il répondre par la négative
pour quelque raison que ce soit
c'est refuser que le problème soit
jamais résolu par la france
s'abstenir c'est choisir l'impuissance
pour la france
voté le projet c'est vouloir que la
france puisse gagner en algérie pour
l'algérie avec l'algérie la cause de la
paix et de la raison
cette démonstration de solidarité
musulmane atteint son but le parti du
fln à l'onu se renforça les pieds-noirs
persuadé que la bataille d'alger avaient
brisé les reins des nationalistes dans
la ville dû reconnaître qu'il n'en était
rien en janvier de gaulle l'emporter
lors du référendum mais la participation
des musulmans travaillé par le fln fut
moindre que prévu les pieds noirs
avaient évidemment dit non mais les dés
roulent est dorénavant pour
l'autodétermination malgré les purges de
nombreux militaires le pardonner par à
de gaulle son changement d'attitude qui
les ulcéré il l'avait surnommé le prince
de l'ambiguïté
m
je
eh bien je crois que de gaulle était
ambiguë spécialement dans la sphère
algérienne pour deux raisons d'abord
parce qu'il n'était pas sûr d'être
immédiatement obéi par tout le monde il
ne faut pas oublier que l'administration
et l'armée française en algérie qui
était très puissante et très nombreux il
y avait environ cinq cent mille soldats
français en algérie étaient en majorité
partisans de l'intégration venir leur
dire de but en blanc comme nous disons
d'un seul coup changer de cap oubliez
les par là vous allez par là il n'aurait
probablement pas été suivi il fallait
des délais et des étapes la seconde
raison c'est qu'il ne savait pas
exactement comment cette affaire se
terminerait je crois qu'au fond du coeur
il pensait qu'elle se terminerait par la
dépendance il l'a dit il avait dit à
d'autres personnes avant 1958 et quand
je les revues plus tard en
1969 il m'a dit j'avais toujours pensé
que ça se terminerait sans doute par
l'indépendance seulement quand on est un
chef d'état et qu'on est responsable du
patrimoine national
même si on pense que telle chose ne
durera pas même si on pense que tel
territoire finira par vous quitter on
essaie d'abord de voir s'il n'y a pas un
moyen de garder des rapports avec lui
les militaires reprochait surtout à de
gaulle de leur avoir caché sa politique
sans doute parce qu'il l'aurait
combattue mais cela devait un jour ou
l'autre aboutir à une confrontation
entre le président et l'a remis
l'armé avait besoin d'un objectif pour
combattre dans cette guerre
psychologique
aussi opposés à l'indépendance de
l'algérie qui était l'objectif du fln
elle a cru avec tout son coeur à
l'algérie française où les musulmans
seraient les égaux des algériens
d'origine européenne et des français de
la métropole
le général de gaulle elle savait
l'algérie française impossible mais n'a
pas su le faire comprendre à l'armée et
a perdu sa confiance nous ne pouvions
pas abandonner l'algérie
et ne pouvions surtout pas laisser
tomber les musulmans qui nous avait
rejoint soit dans l'armée soit
dans les postes de l'administration au
moment des faits la réforme communale
ces types là il ne faut pas oublier que
avant de se décider ils ont dit oui mais
on va nous couper la gorge comme
d'habitude savais que c'était leur
c'était le procédé de persuasion des
rebelles on va mais égorgé
alors est-ce que la france reste pour
nous protéger parce que si la france de
portières nous sommes fichus mon action
est édictée c'est bien simple par les
déclarations du général de gaulle je ne
sais pas si vous vous rappelez des
déclarations du général de gaulle
lorsqu'il est arrivé au pouvoir en 58 il
a dit
l'algérie vive l'algérie française
l'algérie restera français de dunkerque
à tamanrasset
je vous en donne ma parole jamais le
drapeau fln il l'a dit à plusieurs
reprises dans d'autres villes jamais moi
vivant le drapeau fnl ne flottera sur
alger bon il a fait une vingtaine de
déclarations de cette sorte et je mets
l'armée l'armée est garante de
l'exécution de ses promesses par
conséquent je n'ai fait que essayé de
tenir les promesses du général de gaulle
il savait que si la france perdait
l'afrique eh bien c'était ce qu'il
restait de la puissance française qui
serait mis en cause et il faut savoir
que la très grande majorité des français
les officiers français et est légaliste
et que les quatre généraux du putsch
étaient des hommes qui ont eu le même
problème que le général de gaulle en
1940 en 1940 le général de gaulle a
considéré que s'il ne se mettait pas en
rébellion contre le gouvernement légal
français la france était perdu les
généraux du putsch ont eu la même le
même sentiment et c'est ce sentiment qui
a poussé les officiels français et les
parachutistes en particulier entré dans
la rébellion dans l'est
d'où est née fille julie en effet et non
le tourneur
et ce qui devait arriver arriva le 22
avril les généraux challe salants zeller
et joue avec l'aide de quelques colonels
ela conflit civil beaucoup d'autres plus
quelques régiments de parra et de
légionnaires s'emparèrent de pouvoir à
alger
à l'exception de la mort accidentelle
d'un sergent nageurs et il n'y a pas de
victime
leur but sauver l'algérie pour la france
la crise remontait au début mars avec
l'annoncé de l'ouverture de négociations
avec le fln une chose que de gaulle
avait juré à ses généraux qui ne ferait
jamais une trêve unilatérale était
depuis observée par l'armée qui ne
tirait plus sur la sln alors que le fln
ne s'était toujours pas engagé à ne plus
tirer sur l'armée ce qui entraîna la
désertion en masse des harkis à qishan
avait dû ses victoires
d'ailleurs des rumeurs de putsch courait
depuis la semaine des barricades et
surtout depuis la désastreuse tournée de
de gaulle en décembre chose étonnante
paris avait laissé faire comme si la
confrontation il était souhaitée de
gaulle cette fois était prêt à relever
le défi dans son style inimitable
un pouvoir insurrectionnel
7 établis en algérie par un pronom siens
manteau militaire
ce pouvoir à une apparence
un quarteron de généraux en retraite il
a une réalité
un groupe d'officiers
partisans
ambitieux et fanatiques
la réplique fut immédiate il série
d'attentats à la bombe dans une gare à
l'aéroport ailleurs rappelle de la
réalité de la guerre une fois de plus
les rumeurs d'une invasion prochaine
obligèrent le premier ministre deux bris
à prendre la parole
les renseignements nombreux récits et
concordants
permettent au gouvernement de penser
que les auteurs du coup d'état d'alger
envisage à très brève échéance
une action de surprises et de force sur
la métropole et en particulier sur la
région parisienne
ont sorti des dépôts de vieux temps que
chairman vétérans de la dernière guerre
pour garder les établissements publics
comme le palais bourbon où l'elysée et
démontrer la volonté du gouvernement de
se poser à toute attaque des parades
alger beaucoup tombé en panne et furent
remorqué ce que les actualités évitèrent
avec tact de montrer
la police fut renforcé pour rassurer la
population et aussi pour décourager ceux
qui chercheraient à profiter du putsch
mais les parisiens réalisèrent combien
il était vulnérable avec le gros de
l'armée et les meilleures armes en
algérie
les manoeuvres des blindés démontré
surtout la vétusté du matériel
les allées et venues au palais de
l'elysée était bien la preuve d'une
crise grave
les transports publics ne fonctionnait
plus les cafés restait ouvert mais les
salles de spectacles avaient fermé les
vols étaient suspendus à l'exception du
trafic vers la suisse et plus surprenant
vers l'algérie tout arrivant à paris et
est suspect
la gauche réclamait des armes pour le
peuple afin de combattre les parents les
communistes mettait 15 miliciens à la
disposition des autorités
la crise échapper à tout contrôle et de
gaulle réalisais que la mutinerie de
l'armée devait être étouffée dans l'oeuf
nom de la france
j'en dors que tous les moyens jeudi tous
les moyens soit employé partout
pour barrer la route à ces hommes là en
attendant de les réduire
le discours de de gaulle rallia les
français restait à connaître son impact
sur la troupe en algérie là où se
trouvait le noeud du problème en
attendant on se préparait à repousser
l'assaut les parachutistes sur paris
d'anciens ministres des fonctionnaires
des généraux à la retraite des
adversaires acharnés de de gaulle 20
offrir leurs services le complot pour
s'emparer de paris fut déjoué par
l'arrestation de son auteur
2000 parachutistes cacher dans les bois
entourant la capitale il recevant aucun
signal furent facilement dispersé
cependant de gaulle en appeler à ses
compatriotes surtout à ceux dont tout
dépend des soldats en algérie
[Musique]
françaises français
voyez
où risque d'aller la france
par rapport à ce qu'elle était en train
de re de vie
françaises français
et 10 mois
le putsch qui fondera le discours de de
gaulle sans doute le plus efficace de sa
carrière en sont la cause
challes et ses acolytes espérer que le
reste de l'armée rejoindraient leurs
trop rares partisans une fois leur
emprise sur l'algérie démontrer mais
cette démonstration jamais une pure
affaire de plus il s'avéra qu'au lieu
des trois mois de ravitaillement qu'ils
croyaient détenir il n'en avait que pour
quelques jours
la rengaine la plus populaire était
alors la chanson d'edith piaf je ne
regrette rien c'était bien ce que
ressentaient les putschistes au moment
de se disperser challes se constituer
prisonnier pour être jugé pour haute
trahison
les autres se cacher les paras qui les
avaient soutenus se trouvait abandonnés
à leur sort tandis qu'on les ramenait à
leur cantonnement avant de les disperser
ils reprenaient en choeur le tube de
l'époque
[Musique]
non
rien de rien
je ne regrette en rien
ni la b1
[Musique]
nina
vous savez bien les gars
ça
donne rien
non
rien
ma vie
[Musique]
mais moi
on conduit
sympa non
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
alger était assommé les journaux ne
paraissait plus où étaient censurés de
gaulle une nouvelle fois s'était révélée
trop fort pour les pieds-noirs son appel
aux hommes de troupes par dessus la tête
de leurs officiers avaient été une
réussite mais qui poserait des problèmes
de discipline dans les mois à venir
le couvre feu régnaient pour les
européens comme pour les musulmans
l'armée connaissait une véritable chasse
aux sorcières des soldes a dénoncé leur
capitaine des capitaines leur colonel
quinze mille officiers furent accusés
fin avril cinq généraux et 200 officiers
supérieurs passer en cour martiale
les actualités françaises cherché à
faire croire à un retour à la normale
mais il était clair qu'avec la
disparition des pieds noirs en tant que
force politique après la semaine des
barricades et avec une armée en pleine
confusion depuis l'échec du putsch un
vide s'est écrit
[Musique]
c'est alors qu'on vit apparaître trois
initiales aux as organisation de l'armée
secrète on en parlait depuis des
semaines ses fondateurs étaient des
colons ultras rejoints par des officiers
passer dans la clandestinité après le
push de tous les graffitis qu'avaient
connu les murs d'alger ces trois lettres
serait le plus sinistre encore
aujourd'hui
le goal était au pouvoir depuis trois
ans plus fort que jamais mais la guerre
d'algérie durer toujours pis elle allait
entrer dans sa phase la plus sanglante
la plus ignoble
je